everybody welcome to live coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie and today we're gonna
move some data yesterday we spent some
time looking at the database we saw the
structure we started to write some
JavaScript code with node to be able to
pull that data out of the database and
we ended up just pulling out a static
JSON file and then we were gonna put it
into wordpress with the wordpress api
well since that time
Harshit who's frequently in the live
chat and also a frequent contributor
Harshit wrote there kind of the rest of
what we were planning on writing but he
did it a little bit differently so the
way harsha did it is we can pull data
out directly out so basically we skip
the step of exporting it as a JSON file
first so we can pull the data directly
out of the database using sequel queries
right there in our node file we just put
the query in as a string we'll check out
the code in a minute I just wanted to
give harsh that is proper thanks for
this
so basically pulls it out as a query and
then it authenticates with WordPress so
you can get data from the WordPress API
without logging in but you can't put
data in right that makes sense so we
authenticate and add the data into
WordPress and it's it actually worked so
let me pull this over this test so I did
access just with one piece of
information I didn't want to go through
all you know 9,000 plus rows but here we
see this is that test WordPress
installation that we made yesterday and
the first piece of data that we had
here's the correct title now here's the
issue this is the HTML oh goodness I'm
sorry
and then change my screen alright now
I've changed my screen so this is the
correct title in our WordPress
installation and then this is HTML and
there's actually I don't even think
there's content in here it's all just I
guess these tags that are specifying
what components are supposed to go in
here so we're gonna have to look through
some of these and see I guess like what
where are we supposed to get this
content from obviously we don't want to
pull this in so we're gonna have to take
a closer look at the data now so I've
already started to do that and that's
why I apologize are starting to scream a
few minutes late but I got really into
this and I just didn't realize how late
it was so let's take a look at some of
the data we have and we make it bigger
so I can see so one thing that I found
and this is what I was going right
before it stream started is that the
content type of 3 corresponds to I guess
news yeah I think these are all news the
content type for our current system
Extron I think this would be categorized
as news so we don't think we need news
I guess we'll have to verify yeah all
these seem like announcements just some
of these now that I look at it
potentially wouldn't be news hmm this
might end up being a little bit tougher
it seems as if there's not really
separate post types mmm yeah this is
still content type 3 I was I was afraid
this would happen so let me explain a
little bit about what what was done and
this was before I even started working
here from what I understand when this
was was delivered from the company that
built it meaning you know the Ektron
content management system and the
website there were pieces of it that
were supposed to work a certain way and
they didn't so what they ended up doing
was using some let's say like some
content types some post types for a lot
of different things that they weren't
originally meant for which worked at the
time but the problem that we're gonna
have to deal with now is that now when
we have a content type that maybe this
was originally supposed to just be from
news or announcements but now it seems
like they've used it also for employees
like this is a faculty member so
potentially this could be a faculty
profile so we we need to find some way
to figure that out or seize folder IDs
152 maybe the folder IDs would help us
alright let's search for that right now
we're inside 3 let's search by folder ID
what was that 152 is that the one that I
have found 152 all right where folder ID
equals 150 - all right let's see what we
get here
whoa why are you making me log in again
should I get disconnected
well disconnected me pretty quickly
all right yes yes yes yes this is much
better
okay so this is this is better let's cut
this doing you notice for now I just I
want to look at all this data so
eventually we won't cut out the columns
that we need but right now I'm looking
for identifiers so that could help us
group these together otherwise
somebody's gonna have to go through it
by hand so all of these look like
they're faculty profiles these are all
professors associate professors so
that's good probably won't use the
teaser because I want the full content
so we don't need that row but the text
you could figure out the text might be
useful there so we have that content
text we're not getting anything for the
image we have the template oh yes that's
unfortunate because these usually do
have images attached so I mean that's
not it'd be nice if the images came
through as well but it's not the end of
the world I don't want to double-check
what the content hTML is here let's see
what we get so I know this is probably
too small for y'all to see I mean it's
really really small for me I get my face
really close if the HTML structure looks
good then that's probably what I'll
bring in is this content HTML call them
if not then I'll try to bring in just
the the text the plain text and we can
always wrap it in a tag but this
actually looks pretty good when it
actually comes with an image tag with
the image source in it so that's that's
nice yeah that's really nice
great and these also have some YouTube
embeds attached as well and that's in
there
wonderful all right cool I think we have
our first piece of data right so you
know what let me go to live chat I see a
lot of activity in here and I haven't
looked at it yet so I'm gonna live chat
maybe things will change if depending on
what's happening in the chat but
basically my my first idea here is let's
make a custom post type and try a custom
post type called faculty and we'll try
to pull all these in and we will we'll
cut down on the query here only pooling
what we really need but we'll try to
pull those in put them in WordPress and
then see what we get
all right so hey everybody everybody
saying hi here at the beginning let's
see ok cool Brian who works with me here
is in the live chat so that's awesome
because he actually put in a lot of this
content himself or was in charge of
directing other people to put the
content in so he knows a lot more about
this content how its structured some
glad he's able to join ok so brian says
originally what we are looking at those
are those were events looks like some of
them were also job postings he said look
some of those were expired events which
it's kind of what I thought because
they're referencing you know things that
happen you know two years ago deadlines
for things let's see yes harness asking
about what Ektron is based on Brian says
duh it is it's dotnet so do you I don't
know [ __ ] do you remember when we were
editing some of those c-sharp templates
you know a while back if I don't know if
you're in those dreams or not but that's
what would we were working with Ektron
and the database is
sequel server database let's see okay so
hard [ __ ] stalking about the rose yeah
yeah I will get rid of the rose but I
needed them well before the stream
started I needed them because I was
trying to find that some type of
identifier that would give consistent
categories and I think that identified a
might be folder ID I thought it would be
content type but that's not that's not
the case but folder ID metric might be a
better way for us to go so now that I
found that I can get rid of the rest of
the columns that I don't need
Harshit says remove all of the HTML
using a regular expression or something
yeah that's what I was thinking we
should well potentially some of them the
HTML is a mess but other ones like this
the HTML is actually structured fairly
well so I think we it might not be a bad
idea to just keep it as is especially
for some of these you know for instance
for this one I know the tags are weird
but it makes sense the name right and
then we have an image and then below
there's like a body and thing so that's
how we would want to organize that
anyway so I wouldn't probably wouldn't
make these tags called name they'd just
be spans or something but if it'll save
us a lot of time I'm okay with bringing
things in like this we could always
change the names of those tags at some
point if we really needed to
okay so Brian says these are all
philosophy faculty profiles that that
makes sense now yeah okay
actually that's great that's really
great so do you all from one department
this is awesome so what we can do then
is
we can have our faculty custom post type
but then within that we'll have
categories for the different departments
so we can actually input those with the
categories for the department which
should save a lot of time of you know
having to go in and have someone do that
manually later on so that's great we'll
just have to figure out which folder IDs
correspond to which department and that
then we'll be able to do it we may even
be able to you know make some sort of a
Oh in an array you know maybe some key
value pairs that we can just check once
we import it and then depending on what
what ID we get you know would
automatically assign that corresponding
category
I'll think about best way to do that but
I this is good good news okay
okay Brian saying the images also
probably won't be very usable because
they're very small yeah maybe it might
still not be a bad idea to try at least
see what those images are like I'm
thinking like if it comes down to it
right and we need to launch it we don't
have that much time small images are
better than no images we can make the UI
and in such a way that maybe those small
images will look okay and then after we
launch we could certainly go back in and
you know find higher quality images but
the process of going through and finding
good images for every faculty member you
know it that may not be doable in the
amount of time that we have so I I agree
that those images will probably want to
replace them but let's try to keep them
for as long as we can and I do have
access to all these files where these
images are so I could very easily take
all of those images put them into
WordPress or wherever we want to host
our images and then just go through and
in bulk change all those image source
URLs so that's what I'm thinking wound
up doing right because obviously we're
you know we're not gonna leave this
server up where these images are now
okay
I should ask thief's equalised work
efficiently with MS sequel yes it did it
definitely did I had a little bit of
trouble so the only trouble I had and so
harsh its harsh it made a repo with all
this and I forked it so it's now on the
fus mark on github organization so you
can check that out this is the newest
repo I only had to change a few things
so let's show let's get to the code now
I am going to exit
out of my config because I want
everybody to see that but basically what
I had to change is we were defining a
port and in the config it was set as
some other port I just got rid of it
because the default port worked so since
the default port work that was fine with
me and that port would be it's not
showing it enough anyway so figure you
know what may as well save a line if
it's going to give us a default that
works we probably don't can take out now
I don't remember what variable was there
oh yeah I don't remember what variable
was in the config I I assumed it was
just DB port but anyway we don't need
that so that's pretty much it that's all
I had to change I'll go it through here
there's nothing there's nothing else and
I didn't really have to remove that line
I could have just manually typed in the
port in the config but like I said you
know might as well you know take a line
out if we can okay
Brook says hi everyone bit late just got
done eating a lot of fries that sounds
good right now actually I could give her
some fries
okay all right
I should shed his uh visual studio could
set up yes so if you notice I'm using
Visual Studio code partially for some
reason that links not working for me I
don't understand anyway so I have
switched over to visual studio code I'm
gonna try to work with this more I have
noticed the the speed is better for
visual studio code it is I know in the
past I've been against the integrated
terminal but for at least for the stream
it's very nice to have this right here
and not have to switch so I like it
there's still times when I'll I still
have my other terminal windows open on
my other screen so and I think I'll
continue to use both but this is nice it
is pretty nice let me make this a bit
bigger goodness
alright and I don't need that there we
go okay so just very quickly I'm gonna
run through this before we start pulling
stuff over so if maybe you're not that
familiar with node you know maybe you
wouldn't be able to just read this and
know what's going on we'll go through it
so we are using some packages here know
to fetch which we talked about yesterday
sequel eyes so sequel eyes is pretty
obvious I think from the name right that
it helps no talk to the sequel database
right so you can see that we're this is
just connecting to the database but down
here we can actually use the sequel
syntax which is kind of cool I mean I'm
not that familiar with it but it is
pretty cool that you can just you know
send in you know a sequel query just
like you would put it in normally and
then we'll get you know we'll get the
data back once we get the data back we
loop through it
right and then so in this for for posts
of posts then we could do whatever we
want to manipulate that data in here
like we talked about yesterday
and then now this part well this part is
building the data that we're going to
send to WordPress and then this is
actually sending the data so we're
authenticating and sending Harshit also
added a counter
that'll give us a console log for how
many posts have been added so really
nice and I wonder if we could have or
when I ran this earlier I'm gonna give
you an example of let's see before I
guess I didn't get a count last time oh
all right so that's what's going on
let's try to pull in some data now so we
need we're gonna pull this in as faculty
and we're gonna try to give it a
category of philosophy so let's see what
we want do we need an ID I don't think
we need the ID the language we need the
title we need content HTML then we need
the status Brian what's the status mean
we talked about this yesterday right
a is active
but I thought we were it was going to be
a and I like active inactive but we're
getting in oh no we don't need this edit
history I don't think I'm gonna mess
with bring in they created it's okay so
the the o means it's been submitted and
it's waiting for approval alright
Brian's gonna check on that yeah I don't
see any it unless you all think of
something I don't really see any reason
to keep the created date or the names of
the people that put this in now keep in
mind we are going to have a copy of all
this so if we really needed to look look
at this we could go back through I think
I'm going to export it in basically all
three formats that we can export it and
save it and that way we still have
access to this data but just in terms of
what we ought to bring into WordPress I
don't think we need any of this
let's see you let's say we don't need
that we don't a user ID so we'll need
folder ID we don't need a content teaser
do we need published so the publish we
just have zeros and ones does the zero
mean it's not published yet let's go
over and see me yeah you know what maybe
the zero means it's not it's not
published it'd be published at some
point or has it been unpublished you
know purposely
and let's see the other fields here all
right so we don't need any of that
private I don't even see anything marked
as private anyway all right I'm not
gonna worry about template ID we have a
ton of them are just no
okay
whoa what's going on here oh there we go
it's just that was that was odd actually
this is odd as well so these are all the
same but then once we get down here the
titles are odd and there's no content
I'm gonna scroll over and see if there's
any content anywhere maybe we can put in
a check that says you know if there's no
content this is where it kept the teaser
field I think maybe we could say if
there is no content we're not gonna pull
it in either
for your CV maybe are these just
references to - maybe PDFs Brian wants
to see that teaser section let's bring
that up if I hover
yeah it just a gives basic info phone
number email address title yeah but it's
only for the for those last two at the
bottom and I think we have the more data
up here
all right well I say for now at least
we'll say if there's nothing here for
content HTML then we don't put it in
WordPress let's see what's in it for row
36 is that's one small chunk of an
overall piece of the smart form which
creates the faculty page okay so Brown
are you saying that the data that we're
getting here is not it's not everything
we need on the faculty page then tell me
this is showing us you know name image a
little email link to a CV a video and
then there's details so there's some
text so these ones up here seem more
like a complete you know this is
complete you know information on okay
good
that's everything all right then that
seems like it's definitely doable
ideally let me think if we could do this
differently
I'm much
all right let me let me just show you
what you what I'm thinking and you all
let me know whether or not is reasonable
so if I were making these post types
from scratch in WordPress I wouldn't
just have the the content in you know
because this went up glowing which shows
up in that big content editing area for
a wordpress post i wouldn't put all this
stuff in there with HTML right i would
have different fields custom fields so
there'd be a custom field for name title
you know all that stuff the image
wouldn't just be a link to an image that
would be the featured image for that
post type so it'd be a different spot
where you put it in so if possible with
the wordpress api would it be better if
we could find a way to separate these
out based on the names of the tags where
this info is supposed to be and then add
them as these these extra fields
the only reason I mean I think that's it
would be the best way but I'm wondering
is that gonna make it just too much to
transfer all this data over you know
we'd have to go in some of them
hopefully we'll have the same you know
structure so I'm hoping all faculty have
the same structure so we really only
have to build it out once to be able to
pull that data out and put it in I don't
know a little old thing I'm gonna one
does it even make sense what I'm saying
is it clear
number two assuming that it's clear what
I'm talking about
should we try to do it that way I'm
swimming about the time here it's
already December so really there's only
like two weeks that I'm gonna be working
on this in December and then we'll have
the whole month of January and then at
that point so we're really talking like
six more weeks of working on this before
we need to have something that's
reasonably finished so that people can
test
you know what I think I I've talked
myself into the answer here okay
sorry if this is hard to follow I'm
thinking out loud so that you all can
understand what's going through my head
here okay here's the plan
we're gonna just pull the data in as
these big chunks keep the HTML there
we'll get all the data put in we can
always go in after the fact and change
it right so let's say we pull all the
faculty in it wouldn't be ideal but we'd
still up we'd have all the data in there
and then we can just go in with some CSS
later on you know grab these tags as is
and then then you can style it however
we want right at that point we'd have
something that would look good and it
would work to launch after that we could
have let's say some student workers go
in and we would make the real custom
post type with the fields necessary or
better yet we could just add the fields
in to the custom post type that already
has all the data have student workers go
in separate out that data and then once
we have that all separated out we can
just go in chunks and go back and change
or we could change our components or
react components to pick out that data
separately did you know what that makes
sense so essentially we're doing a good
enough solution for launch since it's so
quick but we're still leaving it open so
that it's entirely possible albeit
somewhat time consuming to grow it out
and separate it by hand or even we
wouldn't have separate by hand but or
even try to build out a somewhat
automated way of pulling that data in
and then we can give it the attention it
deserves in small chunks as the year
goes on let me look back at the live
shots you
think about it okay Uncle Pat's is
separating out the different data fields
this better long-term answer from an
architecture standpoint it may not be
the quickest solution for your timeline
that is also right in line with agile
iterations okay cool
all right thank you okay all right I
think that's a good plan for now if we
run into issues in the HTML that we're
bringing in is just too crazy to work
with we can always you know switch that
up that's not you know that's something
that'll be easily changeable as we're
pulling that data in and we'll try to
pull the data in per category so we'll
make it smaller chunks that way we don't
end up pulling in you know nine thousand
rows of data and then realizing after
that oh we messed it up all right we'll
do it in small chunks check it out make
sure it works all right and then we'll
move on it'll be a little bit slower
than just bringing it all in at once but
it could prevent big mistakes okay so
let's bring that in now so what we want
to grab is how did that go I'm gonna
have to keep checking my syntax here
because I'm not okay I'm not great with
sequel so we want
I'm gonna bring in Content ID that way
if we ever need to go back and reference
the original content it'll be really
easy for us to do that with the ID so we
don't really need that and WordPress but
it could be helpful
oh it's an ID there we go
are we separating by commas yeah
it's a Content ID and we need content
title content HTML it should be you know
I thought I'd misspelled it since I
wasn't getting the autocomplete but
looks alright now the content HTML I
think there is only one other thing
did we want to bring this in or I'm
sorry the folder ID I don't think we
need to bring the folder ID in right if
we're gonna pull these in small chunks
then that shouldn't be an issue so this
is all that we'll need to bring in we
are and then we're gonna pull it in by
folder ID so we'll only get these is
there a way put a tick between the
column names on select it looks a lot
cleaner
okay her should sing use limit keyword
okay limit 500 okay I don't I shouldn't
need to use it for this one because
there's definitely not we have 36 rows
that match this but we should we
probably should use it for some of our
bigger chunks trying to catch up here on
a live chat these between concentrating
okay so drum long the saying put put
back ticks between these is that how we
did it I'm gonna even write that for now
like it is for now you write a live look
cleaner but just for for time purposes
I'm gonna leave it like this oh I know
what I wanted to ask is there a way that
I could put let's say a keyword like not
not and it would be HTML content and
then like blank would that work
I may as well try it oops consonants
HTML equals nothing let's try it now
syntax a keyword in odds
all right so I guess I don't know how to
use not if exists
all right great thank you hush it so if
Diggs is 22 it's not showing up or and
okay I could use end can I use content
HTML can I do is not equal to is that a
thing in in sequel I'll try it
nope incompatible and not equal to
operator where column name is not null
okay thank you
Erland I appreciate that is no
[Music]
or just not know is that how it is
interact syntax
I just put is no I need to remove the
site content HTML if not select a show
all right all right well I got rid of
the red line so this is a promising
awesome thank you who's that Erland well
several of you were trying to tell me
what to do here
Berlin ended up having the the syntax
that I ended up using all right so let's
double check and that did not work what
did I mess up so we still got these
we can always just pull this in and I
mean I I know how to check for this in
JavaScript but I think it would be
better to to not pull them in at all if
we know for sure we're not going to need
them
see
it is it's uh
our [ __ ] was the last thing that you're
you're trying to say there it is not
null with she's trying to say the syntax
is supposed to be just not null are you
saying the syntax is not supposed to be
null
I'm not I'm not sure I can try like this
nope okay
it's so not content all right let's try
this all right let's do oh well I've
been going for quite a long time and I
haven't stopped I noticed there were
some questions I haven't stopped to
answer any questions let me let me take
just a 5-minute break here and answer
some questions because normally I don't
go this long without answering anything
so let me try let me answer some
questions here well it looks like
heart's just trying to find the correct
syntax for me I know I saw a question
okay so our Pez says how do you motivate
motivate yourself to code daily I failed
every day I don't know why help me
okay arpeggio you're still there because
you did ask that you know a few minutes
ago so I mean my motivation to code well
number one is I get paid to code and if
I didn't come in and code I wouldn't
have a job so that's a great motivation
when I was let's say freelance right the
motivation still somewhat had to do with
money but to be honest with you I enjoy
coding so I enjoy building stuff and I
enjoy getting better so I'd say it's a
combination and you know leave aside the
whole I have to make money to pay bills
and take care of my family which I mean
that's significant motivator but leaving
that aside I would say it's a mixture of
I don't know competitiveness wanting to
be better at what I do
you know personal pride in that and
trying to do good things in just fun in
enjoyment so yes so there's some times
when I just I have fun coding so I want
to code because I like building things
and there's some times when I force
myself to code because or to learn
something new and try it out because I
want to be good
so I'd say that's you know those are the
motivating factors for me now on like a
really short term scale you can help
yourself you know to get motivated there
have been times when you know you know I
always break up my work with Pomodoro
sessions I think that helps with
motivations because you have all these
really small chunks that don't seem
intimidating and then when you finish
one it feels like a victory even if it
was something small you can actually
move it you know to a different column
in my case I usually use a Trello board
but I've done it before where you know
I'll have let's say like a piece of
candy or a chocolate bar something you
know sitting on my desk and also okay if
I get through this Pomodoro session or
if I get through this task then I'm
going to eat that candy bar right it's
kind of silly but if you need a little
bit of motivation there it is or I'll
say you know after I finish this task
then I'm gonna go I'm gonna then all eat
lunch or then I'll do something that can
be just a like a short-term motivator
just to get you through you know
something really tough so that would
kind of be my my advice if you have a
really hard time getting yourself
motivated you could look into some other
things like you know are you getting
enough exercise are you eating right did
you get enough sleep if you're doing all
those things and it's still there
you might want to think about talking to
your doctor seeing do you have any
health issues there's all kind of stuff
that could cause that you know maybe
some mild depression thyroid problems I
mean there's so many things but first I
try you know try to get yourself
motivated with some of the things I
mentioned first and and then you know
try with exercise and diet I'm not a
doctor at all so you know don't take my
advice is if I was but just for me I've
you know that also seems to help
so hopefully that some of that was at
least useful to you or someone else and
then ultimately if you try everything
and you're still not motivated it could
may be coding is not your thing you know
maybe you should try to find something
that does excite you
to work or maybe just a different area
of coding you know think there's so many
different things you could go into you
in the area of like coding programming
you know engineering you know just maybe
try out some new things do you find
something that you really do get excited
about one more question here in our last
minute of our break and then we'll go
back and get this data transferred over
Oh more says hi hey Jesse I've been
following you for a while I've noticed
that you work on several types of
projects run in back and mobile I was
wondering what is your role in this
company my official title is front-end
developer but realistically I'm I'm like
the project manager as well for all
these projects so my I have full freedom
to use whatever tools that I need
whatever technologies that I think is
best as long as the projects get done so
if I meet the project requirements on
time no one worries about what I'm using
also I mean cost is if I came in and
said I want to use this certain type of
technology it's gonna cost us $100,000
then they care but I usually use
open-source you know that doesn't cost
anything so now I mean if you are using
open-source a lot and relying on it you
should really consider giving back and
certainly I'm open to that if assuming
that my code is up to quality to be able
to be merged then I'll definitely do
that but you know even if I can't do
that I for sure at least try to give
credit to those technologies that I use
on you know posting about it on Twitter
featuring it talking about it on the
stream so I don't want to give people
the impression that open-source means
free with no responsibility right if we
want those open-source products to keep
going and getting better you know we
ought to contribute something you know
donate you know financially or with your
time and your abilities so anyway
so my role is a little bit more than my
title you know would would have you
believe but basically I I do whatever
needs done to get the project done if
that means working with databases you
know that's it if I need to set up
servers if I need to develop stuff
backend stuff you know I do that but at
least usually what I do is front-end it
would be considered front-end although
lately I've been into all different
kinds of things so that's a good
question of all right so let's go back
I guess I'll set the Pomodoro clock
haven't really been using it that yet
this dream but it'll be a reminder I
guess so let me check the live chat see
what we have in terms of syntax to try
to get this where we want okay
okay so we just need
oops
we're not content HTML
okay let's run it whoops oh I think I
forgot I feed that so not gonna work
still need and
hi that's is that exactly no I think
it's something okay
all right now I'm getting a lot in the
chat here uh okay it's wrong were not
showing the prices and before
it's two single quotes okay all right
parentheses Michael saying parentheses
around the criteria all right Michael
where am I gonna put these parentheses I
mean I'm I'm sorry I betrayed me like
I'm someone who knows nothing about
about sequel queries because that's not
really that far from the truth okay so
in the where you put parentheses around
that okay and then put this
- think so Michaels saying think of your
whereas an if statement in JavaScript
with multiple criteria how do you keep
them together okay all right that makes
so much sense what about what's going on
over here why am I getting a line okay
no all right all right it's not working
what am I doing here knots
okay use all right harsh it's in use
double quotes
Mike what is the data type of the ID
column the folder ID probably I don't
know maybe it's not a string it worked
before let me just remove this quickly
to check so oops I didn't put it in to
be honest I don't know what the data
type is or how to find that I mean it it
obviously looks like it's a number but
there's not closer on anything so you
know I know this is a string so I'm not
sure but it is working like like this
okay news how saying does not matter
what data type it is okay we'll just pop
this back in and let's I don't wanna
keep working with it
concentration oh yeah it's not still
give the red stuff invalid column name
contents
text
okay I know
and Connie it's not no okay all right
hmm
okay let's try okay
so there may be Erland says there may be
some space in there which is detected as
content so let's try hard s another idea
remove not before consummation okay oops
hmm
yeah this is still detecting something
in here all right usually comes in these
miracles all right let's try let's try
this this is from Harshit he's saying we
could do not so we're gonna do at the
end for length equals zero shadows nope
I got it says invalid let's make sure I
got that right I mean content you know
rooks asking if spaces increase length
I don't know
it's like lengths
I
greater than one all right let's see if
getting some more stuff here okay so we
have something else here all right let's
try this
and I'm gonna paste this in because it
was a lot okay so now we're saying I
gots to get some weird character there
all right so coalesce character length
content HTML all right let's see what
this does the character character length
is not recognized built-in function name
all right let me check out that I didn't
miss anything I think I've tried
everything that's been suggested so far
let me know if I haven't all right let's
see a Mayan continuity as lengthier
selects
at length continuity okay
all right select content a day like I
was lying throughout another call and be
a query okay let's see
that's not gonna work from now this
okay
hmm all right let me let me read what
else is in here now Javier says Chavez
content HTML less than symbol greater
than symbol type the actual symbols
without spaces I think that's the way
you say not equal for Strings you can't
type this symbols in chat interesting
all right let me try I'm gonna try a
hardship put some in I can just copy and
paste I'll try that first because
obviously it's easy to copy and paste
oops
nope
it's not
so and Vincents and and content asean is
not no I think we did that one already
yeah we tried that so Vincent we tried
that one already and for some reason
it's it's not recognizing those as as
not enough alright Michael I get the the
length column ID thing which it did it
worked but why why do we want the length
of the column ID wouldn't wouldn't be
better to get the length of the HD
content HTML yes what I was thinking all
right
actually this will be useful just to see
what this returns
invalid argument for one of my function
yeah this is not working maybe because
it's a string and the Content ID was an
integer yeah it's an integer just text
okay Michael I you keep typing in length
but it won't let me it won't let me use
length they keep saying use Len
no Anna
alright let's let me think about this
man I wish I had my interns there's a
possibility I might get three interns
and two of the three are supposed to be
good with databases and they probably
would remember a lot of this syntax all
right let's
how about I don't worry about this now
all right late the the whipping post and
content show less than equal in all
right we'll try it we'll try one more
and
C Mon us and what is it less than equal
and less than equal to is that what
you mean less than greater than
hmm
okay I think our problem is that we
can't use this kind of stuff on that
data type so we need to use things that
work on it's calling it @n text which
I'm assuming is the sequel equivalent of
string all right let's see all right so
Umberto has pasted something in there so
let's try that
whoa all right
yeah I was is wrong with this it's not
working
all right I'm not sure what's wrong with
that I'm Berto but I mean it's giving me
it's giving me an error all right let's
try this day length all right Vincent is
saying since its text we have to use
data length so let's try that day length
is greater than zero
okay we didn't get an error but we also
didn't have anything return
see alright so hard [ __ ] has put in a
Stack Overflow link let's check that out
all right I guess we could try this it's
sorry everybody
I've messed up my my sign I didn't see
you all type in that either cuz I was
looking at that Stack Overflow yes yes
all right okay excellent who was that
Vincent Vincent all right great job that
was though that did it
thank you very much let's import this
data all right yeah let's bring that in
actually let's just bring this in
all right so for this here we go and
content titles that was publish I wonder
if we could give it an ID just shut up
[Music]
oops post I still have the API Doc's up
here I guess I could see those I want to
get posting when I post
hmm I guess I can't set the ad did
all right we'll leave it off for now
yeah I'm not really seeing
in a category
let's just just try to pull this in and
see how that's works especially with a
category so let's add a category in
right now we want it to be faculty yeah
okay we'll save that and let's run it
no no no I agree
the hardship is asking how will you
insert folder ID and WordPress how hurts
it does not like a sequel server
yeah I'm not using it by choice this is
just what we have the data on right now
so the last time I ran this it didn't
actually give me any indication that
this worked so let's just check out what
we have here in our or posts see if we
got it hmm we refresh okay
still nothing
all right so that didn't work
that's interesting so we haven't gotten
an error but I'm not seeing the data
use
all right so let's see
nothing good somewhere else go back no
you know what I wonder if what's this I
think probably what I need is the slug
for this and knots I'm maybe it wasn't
adding it because it wasn't that
category so I'm gonna save this and try
it again
mmm-hmm nope I wasn't it
hard saying console of the data okay
let's do that
[Music]
alright let's go
Arsen change the log frequency okay yeah
let's just take this up and then just
console look
okay it's saying that it's inserted but
we're seeing it is not inserted let's
see what did we add up here let's take
this out oh you know what it wasn't that
it was because I tried to add this ID in
and you can't add an ID and I forgot to
take it out so remember we checked the
docs realize the Canadian they never
never anything about it so that's most
likely why try it now there we go
that's why interesting the category
thing did not work though so we had
category faculty let me check the docs
and see category oh okay because I
messed it up it's supposed to be
categories
and it's supposed to be an array all
right
oh well that was kind of a test anyway
so ones have to remember that for next
time
kids categories and needs to be an array
I would like to see what it's what the
update process is for updating a post
okay that's not that's not as good here
so when you go to update you actually
have to put in the post ID I was hoping
that you could just do a post request
now that the yeah this makes more sense
you have the ID all right good to know I
mean I wasn't gonna update right now but
it's good to know that if we ever need
to that's how we got to do it okay so
like I said this is a test so I don't
want to leave these in posts but I did
want to see ok can we add multiple
things and we'll come in and let's check
all right cool we have this in here it
looks weird now but we can check the
HTML and it looks a little bit nicer now
when it actually is pulled in HTML
that's interesting that's X that's
really interesting
it did not pull in all the tags or maybe
WordPress stripped a lot of them out so
if you remember what we should have
oops
is something more like this
alright let's set this with WordPress
for a second
it strips them automatically I don't
know if you saw it was really small but
I tried to put a non-standard
HTML tag in here and it stripped it out
I'm really glad we tested this so I'm
gonna have to look up how to turn that
functionality off for our editor at
least for when we're pulling stuff in
that might not be a bad idea to turn it
off later on to keep people from putting
invalid HTML in here but for now I'd
rather keep that structure okay all
right so we got a lot of done today I'm
pretty amazed that in two days we pretty
much figured out how we're gonna do this
migration I haven't done it but having
migrated everything but we've tested it
enough that we know it's gonna work
still have a few things to work out like
getting it to keep the tags that we send
it but other than that not bad is
definitely a successful stream today so
let me check the live chat quickly to
see if there are any questions that I
missed I think I was able to catch
everything as we were going along and
then I think we'll wrap things up
okay Harshit saying let's change the
tags using regular expression yeah we
could do that I'm just I'm worried that
you know would it be too much so harsh
is saying like try to replace the
content with replace name with div well
that's good but I wouldn't want to
replace it with div it would have to be
like div and then class name right
because I want to I want to be able to
still grab those so would it be worth it
knowing that we would have to go through
and figure out you know for the faculty
it's fine because they're all going to
be pretty standard I hope but then for
each different post type we'll have to
figure out what we want to change the
stuff to maybe it would be easier just
to figure out how to turn off all right
well here's it I'm gonna try to figure
out how to make WordPress accept the
tags that we send it if that's not
possible or if it's really hard to do
then we'll try to just change the the
tags because the tags at the very least
I mean there it makes it obvious what
the thing is so I don't dislike that
those tags and as far as I know html5
it's it's totally definitely okay maro
is a feast day catholic holy day of
obligation so I'm off tomorrow since I
work at Catholic University so I will
see you all on Monday and I'll try to
work on figuring out what's what's going
on with WordPress and we may or may not
do more streams on the transferring this
data because we pretty much figured
how it's gonna work it'll probably be
just somewhat time consuming so I'll
work on it or I'll find you know someone
else to work on it yeah all right so
anyway to anybody who's anybody who's
Catholic have a happy Feast of the
Immaculate Conception tomorrow it's cool
if you don't have to work that's awesome
if you do have to work that's kind of
usual nobody really gets off for that
but make it to Mass if you can and I
think that's it thank you so much
everyone for helping it's really obvious
that I needed the help and I very much
appreciate it so have a have a great
weekend since I won't see y'all tomorrow
and I'll be back on Monday